hi I'm Wolfgang kersnorth and I'm one of
the founders and the pi of the TARDIS
project
there's multiple ways that numb Focus
has supported artists one of the ones is
definitely we have slack which really
helps us communicate we're a worldwide
Community by now and we have students or
researchers from India Germany Greece
China America contributing to this
project and working on exploding Stars
one of the really cool things that numb
Focus does it gives us these small
development grants and we use Google sum
of code to recruit and train students
and some of these students are
outstanding and live in very different
places around the world it allows us to
give these students a little bit of an
extra time to continue working on the
project and I think this is one of the
wonderful things it is not only that we
get to do more science with this and
expand Tardis in the science direction
we also get to grow the open science
Community worldwide